it's all
um
they're by your desk
hey
um
sitting right there
there's
um
so
so we'll talk about it gotcha
what
sorry sexy
what's so funny steve
yes
wait
i'm glad i just needed to
okay
today
um
trying to get back here
so
hello
thursday
thank you very much this is a very big
announcement the biggest ever concerning
drugs and drug pricing
so today i have to tell you it's a great
honor for me to announce that my
administration is issuing two
groundbreaking rules
to very dramatically lower the price of
prescription drugs for the american
people especially
for our cherished seniors we're pleased
to be joined
on this occasion by secretary of health
and human services
alex azer and administrator of
center for medicare medicaid services
seema thank you both thank you both
and thank you all for being here
appreciate it
the unprecedented reforms we're
completing today
are the direct result of the historic
drug pricing
executive orders i signed in july
statutorily we had to go through a very
long process
and we got it done i was very proud to
have gotten this done we were pushing it
very hard
as we did with vaccines and other things
the first action will save american
seniors billions of dollars by
preventing
middlemen famous middlemen they call
them
from ripping off medicare patients with
high prescription prices
currently drug companies provide large
discounts on the price of prescription
medicines including nearly 40 billion
dollars in rebates
to medicare part d plans last year alone
yet often middlemen stopped those
discounts from going to the patients
which is what we're interested in not
the middlemen
who need it the most so the patients are
going to be now getting the benefit
instead of these very
wealthy individuals patients pay
very high prices and they have for many
years although we brought it down
first time in 51 years with the costs
adding up
to hundreds or even thousands of dollars
per year per patient today's action ends
this injustice and
requires that these discounts go
directly to people
these are the people that need it
this will save patients up to 30 percent
could be 40
could be 50 percent could be much higher
than that these are numbers that
nobody's ever even contemplated
and uh that doesn't include life-saving
drugs like insulin which will be even
higher insulin was
destroying lives and destroying families
because the cost was so high and now
it's uh at a level that nobody can even
believe is that correct seymour
35 a month from many times that number
the second rule we're finalizing today
will transform the way the u.s
government pays for drugs to end global
freeloading
on the backs of american citizens and
american patients
until now americans have often been
charged more than twice as much for the
exact same drug as
other medically advanced countries
we would be having a drug
identical drug same company
and we'd pay many times the price of
what that drug
would sell for in certain countries in
case after case our citizens pay
massively higher prices and other
nations pay for the same exact pill
from the same factory effectively
subsidizing socialism aboard with
skyrocketing prices at home so
we would spend tremendous amounts of
money in order to provide
inexpensive drugs to another country and
when i say
the price is different you can see some
examples where the price is beyond
anything four times five times different
for example medicare part b recipients
are forced to spend
five times more for a common breast
cancer medication
than patients in other countries so five
times more
and we have other examples that are
substantially higher than that
to address this unfairness and to lower
prices for americans we're finalizing
the most favorite nation rule remember
that name
most favorite nation rule nobody's ever
done this
the drug companies don't like me too
much but we had to do it
it took a long time before we were able
to do this
because statutorily we had to go through
a process but they'll
they'll never be anything like this i
just hope they keep it i hope they have
the courage to keep it because the
powerful drug lobby big pharma is uh
putting pressure on people like you
wouldn't believe medicare
will now look at the price that other
developed nations pay for their
drugs and instead of paying the highest
price
on the list and we are substantially
higher than any other country in the
world
we will pay the lowest price in other
words we take the lowest price and we
match whatever the lowest price is
leading to colossal savings for all
americans
and we're talking about savings of 50 60
70
80 uh different drugs different prices
in addition today we're taking one more
historic action to hold down drug prices
in the past drug companies have been
allowed to identify certain very
old generic drugs that have been widely
available for decades
and exploit a misguided program called
unapproved
drugs initiative that's unapproved drugs
initiative
a program that has been around for a
long time and
uh hasn't been too good for the
the people that were supposed to benefit
to obtain market exclusivity on these
medicines so
we are doing something that
nobody thought anybody would do the
savings is going to be
incredible then they've jacked up the
prices by as much as 1 000
thousand percent on uh this product
this program is also called shortages of
important medicines today i'm announcing
that we are ending the unapproved drugs
initiative
program to stop this unfair practice
so prices are lifted by a thousand
percent to 5 000
in one or two cases even more than that
and we're ending this we are putting an
end to it
together these reforms will save
american patients many many billions of
dollars
every single year for generations the
american people have been abused by big
pharma
and their army of lawyers lobbyists and
bought and paid for politicians
but i've been loyal to the special
interests i've been loyal to our
patients
and are people that need drugs
prescription drugs
and devoted myself to completely
fighting for the american people you see
that
this is not an easy thing to do big
pharma ran
millions of dollars of negative
advertisements against me during the
campaign which i won by the way but you
know we'll find that out
almost 74 million votes we had big
pharma against
us we had the media against us
we had big tech against us
we had a lot of dishonesty against us
but big pharma alone ran millions and
millions of dollars in ads in fact i
looked at it and said who is it
they uh i've never seen anything quite
like it because
i told them i'm gonna have to do this
you know i was put here to do a job
and fisa and others
were way ahead on vaccines you wouldn't
have a vaccine if it weren't for me for
another four years because fda would
have never been able to do what they did
what i forced them to do and fisa and
others
even decided to not assess the results
of their vaccine
in other words not come out with a
vaccine until just after the election
that's because of what i did with
favored nations and these other
elements instead of their original plan
to assess the data in october so they
were going to come out in october
but they decided to delay it because of
what i'm doing which is fine with me
because frankly
this is just a very big thing a very big
thing
what i'm doing here i don't know if
anyone's going to appreciate it
these people can't even believe it alex
even you can't believe it can you look
at you
so they waited and waited and waited and
they thought they'd come out with it a
few days after the election
and it would have probably had an impact
who knows maybe it wouldn't have
i'm sure they would have found the
ballot someplace the democrats
and the group these corrupt games will
not deter us from doing what is right
for the american people
and i will always put american patients
first
and i think it can never be shown better
than what i'm doing today already we
successfully lowered drug prices for the
first time in 51 years
in september we finalized the rule
allowing states wholesalers and
pharmacies to safely and legally import
drugs from canada
career politicians have promised to
institute this reform for decades and we
got it done
the reason canada and this is going to
be i think just a short-term
fix because until we have the favored
nations fully ready which we hope to
that be in january first i think a very
important thing to say january 1st it's
right around the corner
but i'm giving governors the right to go
to canada
because they'll pray a pay approximately
50 percent less
for their drugs for that they buy for
their states
so the governor's buying drugs for their
states go to canada
they buy the drugs for very very much
less and they'll be able to pass that on
to the people of florida
ron desantis was the first one to ask
what others are asking also and
it's a great thing i mean you'll save 50
they're going to buy a lot from canada
initially and i think ultimately they'll
be
comparing prices you'll get the lowest
price anywhere in the world
so you won't need to buy from canada in
a few weeks my administration will also
finalize rules requiring federally
funded health centers
to pass drug company discounts and
insulin and
epipens directly to patients and the
epipen prices come way down
we remember those horrible stories about
epipen while the price has now come
way way way down we capped insulin costs
for many seniors at just 35
a month as i said saving them an average
of nearly
500 dollars to a thousand dollars a year
just on insulin saving a thousand
dollars a year on insulin
since i took office we've reduced
medicare part d premiums by 12
putting nearly 2 billion dollars back
into seniors pockets now 12
is great by any standard but 12 is
peanuts compared to
what we've done with favorite nations
it's uh
i think it's probably the biggest story
that we've ever had relative to
drug prices there's never been anything
like this this is uh
something that has been talked about for
many years but nobody had the courage
to do it because of the power of big
pharma
we ended the gag clauses that prevented
pharmacists from telling patients
how to buy less expensive drugs as you
know pharmacists
could not talk to patients about how to
buy drugs how about that one i think
that's right
and now they can and should we approved
a record number of affordable generic
drugs
for three years in a row and we put a
very very heavy emphasis on generic
drugs and the pricing there has become
very good but that pricing will also go
down very substantially
no administration has ever fought harder
or achieved more
for our patients and for our seniors
but for america when you think of it for
america because
other countries were paying a fraction
of what we were paying
in some cases a small fraction i mean it
was it was
uh what the numbers were just staggering
the difference between
going to i won't name nations but i
could name five of them right off the
top of my head that
uh it it is so incredible to think about
for years what was happening we've been
working on this for two years
statutorily we had to go through a
process
but when you think that our nation for
the exact same
pill out of the exact same box often
made in the exact same
factory same company
and you take a look at the cost with so
much more
many many times more in four short years
we've instituted the most dramatic
series of drug pricing reforms
in decades and you'll see that it all
comes to fruition right now
starting in january first and the
american people will benefit from our
actions for
many many decades and it should be very
immediate now i presume they'll sue but
it's a suit that they should never be
able to win
they should never ever be able to win so
now i'd like to ask secretary azar to
provide some
more details as to the action and then
seem i'd like to have you come up and
say a word few words and
great job we appreciate it thank you
secretary
well thank you mr president what an
extremely
exciting day for american health care on
top of the news that
you just made today pfizer will be
filing an application for an emergency
use authorization with the fda
for their coven 19 vaccine that appears
to be 95
effective within weeks we could have a
decision from fda
and within 24 hours of that we will have
started distributing millions of doses
of safe and effective vaccine to begin
protecting our most
vulnerable across america you know the
president mentioned his passion for
getting drug prices down and i can tell
you i've seen that firsthand when i
became secretary in january 2018
the very first meeting we had in the
oval office
was to put together our plan
for tackling drug prices it was the
number one priority the president said
for us was getting drug prices down and
in that meeting
we came up with the idea for most
favored nation status
and for ensuring that the discount
prices that big pharma was giving to
middlemen would get passed on to
america's seniors at the pharmacy
counter
and almost two and a half years ago in
may
the president laid out the most
comprehensive vision
for reforming drug pricing in american
history
the president's blueprint was clear we
need to put american patients first
and our drug pricing system too often
puts them
last the system had to change
the blueprint called for tackling for
and free riding
for bringing down high list prices for
reducing out-of-pocket costs
and for better negotiation by our
government programs
that's what the president has delivered
over the last two years already
and that's what the president's
delivering today with these new historic
reforms
we're ending a broken system of shadowy
kickbacks that drove prices higher
and higher every single year and left so
many pace and patients
shocked at the out-of-pocket costs that
they owe
at the pharmacy we're replacing that
system with upfront discounts
in medicare delivered straight to the
patient at the pharmacy
counter we're bringing negotiation to
the way we pay for the most costly drugs
in medicare
fixing a system where the government
just took the price that drug companies
offered
paying about twice as much as comparable
countries
we're ending a program that's been used
by drug companies to jack up prices
on order drugs the president's actions
today boldly take on the big drug
companies
take on the middlemen and take on
foreign countries free riding
off of americans if you don't believe
how fiercely special interests have
fought these efforts you must not have
watched
any tv in washington over the last
couple of years
special interests have run millions of
dollars in ads against the president's
drug pricing initiatives
mr president they understood me and they
sure as the devil underestimated you
about two years ago just over in the
roosevelt room the president signed
legislation to ban
pharmacy gag clauses alongside me
and his drug pricing advisors that
included my friend
and colleague dan best who passed away
two years ago this month
and he devoted his life to lowering drug
costs for american patients putting up
them at the center of our health care
system just as president trump has done
and he was one of the key driving forces
behind the rules that we are announcing
today
i wish dan could have been here today mr
president but today's actions are a
lasting legacy for him
and for you the president's historic
actions
will transform drug pricing forever and
build the system that american
the american people deserve a system
that puts american
patients first thank you so much mr
president
for making today
[Music]
masks and hoop earrings don't work
thank you mr president for your
leadership and let me take a moment
to give some context for today's
announcement from day one
president trump made it very clear that
he wanted to make health care
more affordable and accessible to every
american
and the most important thing is that he
wasn't afraid
to take on the special interest groups
to get this goal accomplished
and in the absence of any meaningful
legislative support
this administration has delivered real
tangible results
premiums down in medicare by 34
the lowest in 14 years and some areas
saw
declines almost as much as 60 percent we
stabilize the exchange
lowering premiums for the first time and
brought back more plan choices
we have set forth a pathway to make the
american health care
system work more efficiently to deliver
better quality and lower costs
tackling long-standing problems that no
other administration had the guts
to do and the list is long price
transparency so that patients know what
they're getting charged
before they get their care portable
digital health records so patients have
their complete medical history
right on their phones reducing
regulatory burden so that doctors can
spend more time with patients
the health care system will work better
because of what this administration
and president trump has accomplished and
as the president noted our achievements
on drug pricing are no less sweeping and
unprecedented
thanks to regulatory changes in 2017 the
part d
premiums have dropped to some of the
lowest rates in seven years
saving beneficiaries over 1.9 billion
dollars in premiums
and we're also bringing price
transparency to medicare so that doctors
and patients have pricing information
when drugs are prescribed so that
patients can get the best deal
the president's senior savings model has
our medicare beneficiaries cheering this
year
as they are selecting plans in this
year's open enrollment
they have over 1600 plans that are
offering insulin for just 35
a month or less and that is a massive 66
savings today's announcement is about
part b
where the medicare program has been
nothing but a powerless
price taker and the problem is simple
while there are market forces and
negotiations that serve to reduce costs
in other parts of the health care system
it just doesn't exist in part b which
pays for drugs
that you get in a doctor's office cancer
drugs and other infusions
in part b american seniors and taxpayers
pay
whatever drug companies want to charge
and doctors also get paid a percentage
add-on
so the higher the drug costs the more
they get paid
giving an overt incentive to prescribe
higher priced drugs and for
manufacturers to increase his prices
and so it's no wonder that american
seniors are paying twice as much as what
other countries are paying
and because of this over the past five
years
medicare spending for part b drugs has
gone up
by 55 percent on average and drug
spending in part b
is responsible for over a third of the
premiums that our seniors pay
so the bottom line is higher drug costs
lead to higher premiums and higher
co-pays
doctors do well drug companies do well
but patients pay more this effort is
going to save over
85 billion over seven years and saving
seniors over 28 billion dollars
as well and so i want to thank the
president
for being a problem solver and willing
to be
to think big and to act boldly on behalf
of the american patients his record of
success over the last four years is a
testimony
to that mentality thank you thank you
sir
you